the Joe Rogan experience is there any
other way to handle this in terms of
quarantine or social distancing like is
there would there would it be possible
to quarantine the people that are at
most risk instead of the general
population
well well again the problem gets to the
fact that you know again there's this I
the this is only among older Americans
and people over the age of 70 diabetes
hypertension but now we as the Centers
for Disease Control has been reporting
we've had this big flux of young adults
getting very sick and in the ICU so what
point do you say pretty much everybody
potentially is at risk then among the
children even though the the children
generally are children adolescents seem
to do pretty well with this virus now we
realize our from studies coming out of
China it was published in the journal
called Pediatrics put out by the
American Academy of Pediatrics about ten
percent of infants are getting very sick
with this virus so infants are at risk
so you start adding it up okay older
people those underlying diabetes
hypertension and younger adults and 40
and 50 year olds as well and we're
hearing all these stories on CNN and
elsewhere about you know valued
colleagues you know in their 50s and
that kind of thing getting really sick
or even even dying and then infants
after awhile it's just it's you can't
you can't slice it that fine it's it
becomes impossible to do it
[Applause]